Hey guys, Trace here today on World AIDS Day
for a DNews Short.
AIDS is an incurable disease that occurs when
the human immunodeficiency virus has overwhelmed
the immune system.
AIDS is a syndrome, a condition… while HIV
is the virus that causes it.
There’s no known cure for HIV...yet.
But in a new study, researchers from the National
Institutes of Health identified an antibody
that can neutralize 98 percent of the 181
HIV strains they tested!
That's right, an antibody that can win the
fight 98 percent of the time!
This is HUGE news.
HIV is a vicious virus that attacks T cells,
which protect the immune system from infections.
Without proper treatment, the body’s T cell
count goes down.
If it drops below 200 T cells per cubic millimeter
of blood, HIV develops into AIDS.
But the researchers at the NIH think the antibody
they found can help neutralize HIV, and therefore
prevent future cases of AIDS.
Quick refresher, antibodies are made by the
immune system.
They are proteins that defend against dangerous
substances in the body called antigens.
The antibody these researchers found is called
N6 and it fights against HIV.
(Go N6!)
HIV is one of the fastest evolving organisms
known to man.
One single virus can reproduce billions of
replicas in one day!
And since the copies are made so quickly,
HIV can adapt when it senses a threat and
we’ve struggled to find an antibody that
can effectively respond to it… until N6!
N6 keeps up with the mutations by attaching
itself to the parts of the virus that rarely
change (rather than the parts that morph),
and neutralizing the virus.
By doing this, N6 prohibits the HIV from latching
on to immune cells and attacking them, which
is what can cause HIV to develop into AIDS
.
This discovery is especially exciting because
researchers think N6 could be the key to creating
an HIV prevention vaccine and effective treatment
for the currently incurable condition.